yet Showtime Linz Evan Cannella flat
seven kilala of Linz Evan Turner la puna
bitching with hips that swivel like this
Hosanna Khan has added his own exotic
touch to the cologne comedy scene here
he's working on his act with his partner
Tunch Tennessee a playful subversive a
bit of review a bit of ethnos a tire
osanic on calls it hybrid comedy he came
to Cologne 20 years ago from Izmir don't
give up old now he's a regular performer
at carnival and a cologne fan through
and through Cohutta goals are hats
cologne has a big heart
the Ryan is here the cathedral is here
cologne is beautiful and multicultural
there are plenty of Turks here and we're
all very very happy isn't here Allah Zia
Zia Glueck leash Azana Khan's first
recommendation isn't far from the city
center the sculpture park right on the
banks of the Rhine the 25,000 square
metre park is filled with works by
international artists such as Japanese
architects so Fujimoto others include
German sculptor and painter York in
Medora conceptual artist - jenny holzer
from the US and dan graham also from the
US he designed this maze
assurances Jesus Park the best thing
about this park is that it combines
nature with modern art tool the natural
surroundings are gorgeous the trees and
flowers at the art the modern art is
really beautiful here is Berkeley Gunda
sure
Vons ambulance rabbits d Hassan
this is bill - this is colognes famous
quotes - awesome as the locals say
keupstraße
some call it little istanbul welcome
this is een as you see we turks need
seven lanes one two dry run in seven two
parking
koib Strasse Hosanna Khan's second tip
is in the mülheim district of Cologne
many of the more than 100 shops belong
to shopkeepers of Turkish to send you
can get Turkish CDs and bridal wear and
of course great food in the restaurants
koib Strasse is a shopping street with a
special touch this is a class here is
little Istanbul got a Turkish days
typically cologne Turkish coach
yes Allah but first let's eat some tasty
baklava hello BAM baklava store she will
be tobacco what I've ever seen mmm
that's this is the best baklava
this one has pistachios and that one to
Nick house Oh sonic on assures us that
in the baklava bakery you can get the
very best typical Turkish pastries
better than those in Turkey they should
close with him
last piece to know what more could you
want
tea tea and baklava no I'm ready to go
again
his last tip leads us back to the river
this time on the other side of the Rhine
oh seung-ah Khan thinks the rhyme
Terezin restaurant is especially worth
visiting when the weather gets warm
during the day is a cafe and restaurant
and in the evening a club he wouldn't
mind spending the whole day there an
assurance oblique does the best thing
here is the view of the cathedral with
the Rhine between us as food water is
really important to me water cleanses my
soul
the Danish - even when I'm tired or in a
bad mood what did I come here drink a
coach looking everything's fine again
what linkage and coach one edit video
you